[Music]
[Music]
today i'll talk
about a friendly introduction to deep
reinforcement learning
and policy gradients so i want to thank
manny for inviting me to the
twitch channel to talk about this so
first i'll tell you that i
am one i'm one of the manning authors so
i wrote a book
called uh rocking machine learning which
is about to go out and press
and you can get the the meep uh already
online and uh manny has provided a
code of 40 discount on not only this
book but
all the books in uh
in in in the it had manning
and the code is twitzer 40.
so i'll i'll be displaying it again
later but uh feel free to use it
so in this book i talk about supervised
learning which is one of the branches of
machine learning probably the most the
most popular and the first one that that
one would learn
uh but in this talk i will tell you
about something different
i tell you about the reinforcement
learning and it's something i touch
in the book briefly and it uses a lot of
things that
that are in the book um but it's not
there it's a
it's it's a more advanced topic so i
will
um first tell you about some
applications of reinforcement learning
so some applications are pretty much all
the
all the cool cutting edge stuff so
self-driving cars use reinforcement
learning
robotics use reinforcement learning and
uh things like playing go and chess you
know how the
computers already beat humans at at go
and that
and that chess um
these are these are applications of of
reinforcement learning
uh because pretty much reinforcement
learning is about it's about
doing tasks so for example in predictive
machine learning
which is what we learn on the rocking
machine learning book
then you you have a bunch of data and
with that data you build a model
and use that model to make predictions
to answer questions like yes or no
or to give you numbers etc uh
reinforcement learning on the other hand
you don't have the data you simply have
an environment which can be a grid or
something
or a game or a terrain
or a city with streets or just anything
a bunch of points and you have an agent
and the agent is the one that acts
and so the agent basically moves around
the space
looking for prices or punishments or
anything like that
and in that way it collects data so we
have it's a completely different
problem although all those similar
techniques that work for one work for
the other one
and so in this in this in this talk i
will tell you about several things one
is markup decision process then the
bellman equation
q networks and policy gradients so we'll
we'll get to each one of these
at the right time first i'll tell you
about mark of decision processes which
is the simplest version
of reinforcement learning so here's the
the
main setting we have today we have
something called the grid world
which is just just a grid with squares
and we have an agent which is this
little dot
over here and the point is that the dot
moves around the space and there are
some
some boxes that have special special
things
for example if you land here you get a
lot of money if you also land
here you also get money and here there
is
a dragon and that dragon
eats you if you um if you
fall there and you lose the game so you
win if you get to the money and you lose
if you get to the dragon
and so just to put some points you get
five points if you get to the money on
the top
right four points if you get to this
money and
minus one if you get to the dragon
that's that's the rules of the game
furthermore there are some barriers and
you cannot cross those barriers
so the point is to teach the agent to
play this game
and win as many points as possible so
for example if the agent does
this then it gets a four and you record
that
but if the agent does this
then it loses one point so we record
that
and if it does this then you get a five
video you don't have to
to start in the bottom left corner you
can start anywhere you want
so that's the game now we're going to
figure out a strategy
for the agent to win at this game
okay and so for that i'm going to teach
you a bunch of things value states
actions and and policy so
value and and policy work in the
following way imagine that i'm gonna
have one of the squares in the grid
that's the one on the right
and let's say that it has four neighbors
it doesn't have to have four neighbors
so i'm gonna have three or two
but this one let's say it has four
neighbors
and so each of the boxes is called a
state
and the actions are the four things you
can do so you can go up
down left and right and
uh there are some values so
i'll tell you a bit more about this in a
minute but imagine that
going to the right you you win four
points imagine that going up you gain
one point
going to the left you may lose three
points
and going to the bottom you gain two
points so that's
what we have so far in in this
particular square
so then if the question is where would
you want to go
right if you are if you're in this
situation where you want to go if you
want to gain the most amount of points
well clearly you would want to move to
the right right so
these are these are the values by the
way everything in a box is a
is a value so the minus one the plus
five and the plus four you see on
the left are our values and so
clearly we want to move to the right so
the new value for this box
is 4 because it's the maximum i can get
if i play
intelligently right i get a 4. so
in that way the equation basically says
that the value of a box
is the maximum of the values of the
neighbors because if i have a neighbor
with high value
i can just walk towards there and win
so what happens what happens
now well look at the neighbors of five
right the neighbors of five
are gonna get values of five because
they can easily walk into the five and
the neighbors of the neighbors of five
will also have a value five
and actually pretty much anything will
have a value of five because
from anywhere i can walk towards the
five and gain five points so this is a
pretty easy game
and don't worry we'll we'll make it
harder but this is
a pretty easy game uh and uh
and uh basically we have something
called a
policy which is the arrow that points at
where you should always move
i think of it as a supermarket during
covet with arrows on the floor that's it
go in this direction go in this
direction so
if you you know the policy here is
pretty simple is
basically try to walk into the five and
try to avoid the four
and try to avoid the minus one because
if you walk into the four the minus one
you don't gain five points
and so the idea is this is a good policy
it says
follow any of the arrows do whatever you
want and if you fall in if you walk into
a wall
you stay where you are so you just don't
lose anything
um so that's a good policy obviously
that policy may make you walk around a
lot and
make you waste time so maybe something
like this is better when you don't walk
into walls
and there's still something much better
right like we can still
um do a little better so for that
now i'm going to teach you something
that will help you not
make the robot walk in circles forever
and just
waste time and for that we go to the
rewards
so the rewards is basically we don't
want
the the agent to be moving around we
want the agent to go straight to the
money
right and for that we're gonna create
a it could be a reward or a punishment
but it's called a reward
so we're in the same scenario as before
you can go
if you go to the right you get four if
you go up you get one if you go to the
left you get minus three and if you go
to the bottom you get two
so obviously here you wanna move to the
right
however now we're not going to say that
we gain four
because it's expensive to move a robot
one box so we're going to lose one point
every time we move the robot so it's
like
gasoline or something it just wastes
energy
um and so this is the reward of minus
one
so if i move into a four i now have a
three if i move into a one i now have a
zero if i move to minus three
i now have a minus three and if i move
into a two
i now have a one and now i still pick
among
among the the maximum of this so i still
wanna move to the right except that now
i have a three so my new equation
it says that the value of a box is the
maximum of all the
neighbors of minus one
plus the value of the neighbor right it
says basically
always move until your hot always move
in the direction of your highest
neighbor
but every time you move you're gonna
lose one and that's gonna prevent the
agent from
walking aimlessly because it's not gonna
it's gonna lose points when it walks
aimlessly it's just gonna wanna really
get to that 5 or that 4.
uh so here's here's uh the neighbors of
5
now have value 4 because you walk into
the 5 and you get a
you you subtract 1. these ones have
value 3.
now let's look at the neighbors of four
they have value three because you can
walk into the four
right now these have value two and we
can continue propagating this
right and um the neighbors of the one
minus one will have a value of minus two
and sometimes we'll propagate this and
we may have to we can
recalculate some things that's
completely okay
but let's propagate it like this so take
a look at this and i hope you agree with
me
that the that the values of each box is
that because you can always
sort of walk if you walk into the
direction of of the increasing value
you will get to the the most points you
can get from that particular position
so here's a policy it's a policy that
always points into
the square of highest value
um so what happens here let's say that
our agent is in the bottom
uh the orange agent right beside that
minus one so the policy says walk into
the minus one
why would one walk into the minus one
and lose a point
well because it's better to lose one
point by walking into minus one then
going all the way to the five
and losing many many many points right
if you think about it i like to imagine
you know if you if you go all the way up
you lose a lot of points you gain five
but you lose a lot more points
whereas if you walk towards here you
only lose one point
i think of it as if like if you are
somewhere outside of your house and
you really have to go to the bathroom
and there's a really nice one like 10
kilometers away
but uh you don't want to go that far you
you're in a rush so instead you kind of
go to the okay one or maybe the
the not so nice one because it's much
closer so
it's just a strategy that you play right
so this game
makes us change your strategy there's
another way
that uh makes this change a strategy
with the discount factor by the way
there's any questions feel free to ask
them in the chat
i can see the chat right here so the
discount factor
is is similar to the reward what it does
is it says a dollar today is worth more
than a dollar tomorrow because it's
better to have my money today than if
i'm gonna
receive it tomorrow right i can put it
on interest or i can
do whatever uh and the same thing with
the day after every every time i earn a
dollar later
is worth a little less than if it's than
if i have it
today uh let's say that today's fourth
one
and tomorrow is worth 90 cents because
my discount factor is point nine
and the next day is worth point nine
times point nine which is point eighty
one and the next day and the next day
every time
it a day every time a day passes before
i get my money it's gonna be worth nine
every dollar is gonna be worth 90 cents
of what it was worth the previous day
and so again that point nine is the
discount factor
and what we do is that every time we
make a step
if we walk into and get a 4 then the
previous box is not going to have a 4
because the 4 is what we get tomorrow
today i'm going to have a 4 times 0.9
so if i walk into this 4 i get 4 times
0.9 if i walk into
the 1 i get 1 times 0.9 and the same
thing for all the other boxes
right it's always what you get times 0.9
and you still want to go into the into
the best one so you
you still want to go into the four and
so my new equation now says
that the value is the maximum
of the values of the neighbors times the
discount factor which is
nine so now it's going to be 3.6 because
i still want to go towards the four
it's my best strategy but i multiply by
value by 0.9
so if i'm gonna fill my start filling my
my squares
well the neighbors of the five get four
four point five
just five times point nine their
neighbors of the
plus four get a 3.6 and you can continue
propagating this and notice that these
are these are the values so if
i'm at any square i can walk towards
either the five or the four and gain
that many points
so here's a policy that points into the
direction of highest gain
every time so
all right so now we can combine
everything into something called
the bellman equation and what the
bellman equation does
is um
is combining the two previous ones so we
had an equation
with uh with a
a reward that would lose one point every
time we make a step
and we have another one with the
discount factor which multiplies it by
0.9 every time we make a step
and so the value total value equation
we can combine these two so every time
you make a step you lose one point
and your money multiplies by 0.9
that you would have earned there and
that's the bellman equation
these are the values of the states uh
these over here are the actual states
the actions are a in blue those are
going up left down and right
the reward is in red is the minus one
and the discount factor is the point
nine that that you lose every time you
that money multiplies every time so the
actions again
up down left right the reward is -1 and
the discount factor is 0.9
so if i have a box for example this one
with my four neighbors
i always want to walk into the one of
maximum value
but my new value here is calculated as
four which is what i win times
point nine times and i mean minus one so
it's
times the discount factor minus the
reward so 2.6
so that's how i'm going to propagate my
values now
for for this talk i'm not going to
to use a discount factor because that
makes the numbers messy so i'm really
just going to say
actions is up down left right rewires
minus 1 and the discount factor is one
so let's forget about that
thing where they where you where you
lose where your dollar tomorrow is worth
90 cents for a dollar today then that
dollar tomorrow is worth exactly like
like a dollar today we're just only
gonna lose one point
for for moving
so now let me show you how to solve this
bellman equation because i've told you
about development equation but but how
do we solve it
well the way we solve it is very simple
we start picking random boxes we pick
this box
and well we don't know anything about
this box because
the neighbors don't have any value so we
skip it
we pick this random box and again the
neighbors don't tell us anything
and so we don't know very much but then
one day we get here
and if we get here then one of the
neighbors is plus five
so because one of the neighbors is plus
five my value here is four because
remember i lose one
one point every time i move to a box so
i can guarantee that if i'm here i can
guarantee a four
by moving to the right if i'm here i can
guarantee a three by moving down
if i'm here i can guarantee a minus two
by moving to the right to the left and
earning minus one points
right and i can continue
if i'm here for example i can guarantee
a two
because i walk to the left and get a
three if i'm here i can guarantee a one
and if i'm here i can guarantee a zero
again applying the bellman equation
but now look at what happens if i'm here
bellman equation says the maximum of the
neighbors minus one
so it's a three but now that zero
underneath has to change
because now the value for that one is
not a zero
but it's a two because the one on top is
a three right so remember the maximum of
the neighbors
minus one and so you may have to
recalculate these values and that's okay
you just go over all the boxes
recalculate calculate we calculate
until eventually i hope you you believe
me that if you do this many many many
times
you will you'll get a full grid uh with
boxes completely numbered with it with
the actual value
so that's the that's that's how you
solve it and then to get the policy
you simply at every point you draw an
arrow towards the highest value around
you so
the highest of your neighbors that says
always walk so notice that
if you're close to the five you kind of
walk into the five if you're close to
the
three you kind of walk into the three
and uh so there's a small mistake there
you want to walk into the one
when you're in the bottom right but
anyway
here's a problem that required a lot of
computation because you have to walk
into
every single box many many many times
that's not good
uh because imagine if you had a
humongous
grid with many boxes and many actions
well by the time you fill this in it's
going to take forever
so what we do is we fix this
using neural networks so it doesn't
matter if you know if you don't know
what neural network is don't worry i'll
i'll show enough of what
we need to know uh but a neural network
looks like this
and we're gonna have two networks one
for value and one for policy if you want
to learn more about neural networks
i'll give you two options one is to take
a look at this video that i have on
youtube
and search for a friendly introduction
to deep learning and neural networks
later i'll show you my youtube channel
uh or you can read rocking machine
learning but i have an entire chapter
on neural networks so we have all the
explanation of
how they get trained how they solve
problems with an example of
uh image recognition and how to code
them so
so take a look at that and um
but going back to this the idea
is that we don't want to visit every
single box we want to visit a bunch of
them
and with that information we want to
sort of propagate it to the entire
network
that's what we're going gonna do because
here in this grid
we have way too much information what we
would love to do
is to store it in less for example
if if this if we're gonna solve the
problem of of winning in a game of go
then every configuration of the board
is a state
and any action that you do any pebble
that you put
is an action and so there's already more
states in a game of go than the number
of atoms in the known universe so you
wouldn't be able to store
all that information all that bad all
those values you will not be able to
store them
even if you manage to store
something in every atom of the known
universe so
you need to crunch this information into
smaller into a much much smaller space
and that's what we use the neural
network for
um but before we get into neural
networks
let me tell you a bit about the strategy
that we're going to play so strategy is
very well known in
reinforcement learning called explore
exploit
so there are two types of strategies one
is called deterministic and one is
called stochastic
and let me tell you a bit about sort of
how it is it's just a way to search the
space
for solutions so let's say that we have
our agent here
and there's some money there and there's
a lot more money on
on over there and let's say that we have
figured out a policy that says
walk towards the the dollar bill and so
it's and it says you know only walk
towards the dollar bill
so deterministic policy
uh now if you don't give the agent the
the chance to explore the space that the
agent is
may never figure out that there's a lot
more money upstairs you know once the
agent figure out some small price
it will continue going towards that
price and it will never be able to
explore the rest
however if we have a much smarter policy
it's a stochastic policy
where you say you know what agent i
think i just found
out there's a bill in front of you so
walk towards that one with
much higher probability but still give
the other chances
the other um directions a chance
so you can still go up with some small
probability and left to somewhat
probability and write some small
probability
and at every point you have some
combination of arrows
and then you make the agent walk and the
agent will walk a little a little
aimlessly which may not get to the bill
as fast as the other agent but it has
chance to explore the space
and maybe find out a lot more money
upstairs
so that's the that's the difference
and the next second is called a
stochastic policy it's much better
than a deterministic policy so we're
going to use a stochastic policy
a deterministic policy is the one that
always tells you one arrow
and it says basically always move to the
right or always move up or always move
left you know from that box stochastic
policy will say okay you you want to
move towards the bigger number
so we're going to give you a more a
higher you're basically going to flip a
coin
or or roll a die with four faces
and with 65 probability let's say you're
going to move right which is the highest
value and with
smaller probabilities you're going to
move up left and
and down uh and that's
um and that's what we're going to do
we're going to do a stochastic policy so
in the left we have a deterministic
policy
that basically tells the agent where to
walk
with no with no room for for exploring
whereas the stochastic policy will tell
the agent
uh how to move around the space but
it'll give it room for
for sort of moving around and and
exploring a little more
so given that i'm gonna tell you about
neural networks
so why do we use neural networks again
or the reason i
told you before is because we don't need
to visit every single box
right a neural network you know we don't
have time to visit all the boxes
several times so what we're gonna do
is we're going to use the following
observation let's say
that i have figured out the value for
this box
well whatever the value for that box is
is going to be similar to the ones
around it
because if i make a lot of money by
being this box and walking intelligently
then probably from similar ones i i make
similar amounts of money
and the same thing for its neighbors and
its neighbors so basically
the value for a box really influences
its neighbors in the same way if i have
a
if this is a very bad zone then the
neighbors are also a very bad zone and
their neighbors are also in a bad zone
and so on
because i said the value of a box
uh really influences the the neighbors
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to take the coordinates of the box
x and y and put them into a neural
network just a function with an input
and an output
and the output's going to be the value
for that box
okay so that's how the neural network's
gonna look
input are the two coordinates of the box
and the output
is gonna be the value and so in that's
the value neural network
now the policy neural network is going
to be similar but it's going to come on
the prem
it's going to be based on the premise
that if the policy for
this box with coordinate sxy is this one
it says go up with higher probability
and then to the right with a slightly
less and so on
well the neighbors probably have a
similar policy right because you
probably want to walk in the same
directions if you're in boxes that are
close to each other
so therefore by only knowing the policy
and a few points i can sort of
interpolate the others
and that's the concept of a neural
network again so for the va for the
policy neural network
i am going to input two things which are
the coordinates
of my point and i'm going to output four
numbers
and those four numbers are the
probabilities of going in each one
of the four directions so that goes
there so basically it's a neural network
that if i enter two numbers
i output four numbers so i enter the
coordinates of the point
and i output four numbers that add to
one
which are the probability of going up
the probability of moving right the
probability moving down the prone to
moving left
okay so in summary we have the value
neural network
which guesses the value of every point
and the policy neural network
which guesses sorry about that the
the four the probability of going in
each of the four
directions so i will um
[Music]
i will now tell you about each one of
them how do we train our value neural
net
so here's the premise okay if we have
basically the idea of the network is if
we have this value
we kind of know a little bit of the
neighbors and if we have this value we
kind of know a little bit of the
neighbors
and we can continue like that until we
know
all the information there is so again
the input for example if i want to find
the value
at the 0.45 i just use the neural
network
to get a value 4 and that's going to be
my value
okay so i'm going to tell you how to
train it the way we want to train it
is by forcing the neural network
to satisfy the bellman equation remember
that bellman equation that if you
it says always move in the direction of
the maximum and the maximum
value that your value is going to be the
maximum of the values
around you plus the reward and times the
discount factor
so let me do a small a small one over
here let's say that we
have a neural network that we have
initialized right and you know again you
can think of it as
an input and an output and you want to
find the right neural network that gives
you the
the output for what you want okay
so let's look at the box two comma three
okay the box two comma three if you put
two three
in the neural network it's gonna output
some value let's say it's zero point two
so that's gonna go here now let's do the
same thing for the neighbors we put in
two comma four
and get another random value these
values are pretty much random because
the network hasn't been properly trained
so it gives us a 1.3 for the one on top
a minus 2.7 for the one on the left
and let's say it gives us for the one
underneath a 4.9
so now we have the same scenarios in the
beginning right
what would the value be for the one in
between in the middle
well it would be the maximum over all
the four actions i can do
over all the four neighbors of minus one
the reward plus the value
of that state so therefore
my neighbors are 3.2 1.3 minus 2.7 and
4.9
so if i subtract 1 to all of these i get
2.2 0.3 minus 3.7 and 3.9
and so i pick the maximum of those and
my value should be 3.09
so it used to be 0.2 now it's got to be
3.9 so i'll tell the neural network you
know what neural network
for the 0.32 i don't want you to give me
a 0.2 anymore now i want you to give me
a 3.9 so we tell that information to the
neural network
neural networks do that they take
features and labels and they try to
match
the features as they put with the they
try to
output the correct label to the feature
so it tells
you know what when i give you a 3.2 try
to output a 3.9 more
and uh so that's what the neural network
does now you know what this takes tiny
steps so it's not going to go all the
way from 0.2 to 3.9
but it may get you farther and the way
you train it is using an error function
so the error function
is going to be how far are you from
satisfying the bellman equation
so if you have your your your value
is 0.2 and your error
your your the value according to the
bellman equation should be the maximum
of those
four things which is 3.9 so your
function
can be what you have minus what you want
squared so that gives you a large number
and so if you do this many times
you'll train the neural network to the
weights to get a little better and to
give you a better value it's not going
to go all the way to 3.9 but it may be
0.45 or something it's just gonna
slightly increase
and so you can imagine that if you do
this many times if i take a box
apply the bellman equation and train the
neural network if i take another box
apply the bellman equation
and so on i will eventually start
training my neural network to become
better
and better and better at predicting
these things and there's going to be a
point
where this neural network is just going
to be beautifully trained and it's going
to get
catch all the values off of the value
function
so that's pretty much how you train a
value neural network
uh and then now when you have an agent
all the agent has to do
is walk into the direction of the
highest gain at every point
okay so we managed to define all the
values without visiting every box
uh so now let me tell you about the
policy networks are
actually a little bit more popular than
the
value neural networks and they they work
like this so we call that
what i want is to build a neural network
that
if i input the coordinates of the point
uh it outputs four numbers which add to
one which are the probabilities of going
up
left down or right and it looks like
this it has two inputs and four
outputs these outputs are the four
numbers uh that that tells us with how
much probability to go
up right down or left
so let me tell you how to train this
neural network okay
the way to train it is the following
let's say that we have
some random some random initializations
or random weights and it's going to give
us some
some values for each one of the
directions at each box
it's probably not the one we want uh but
let's let's make
an agent walk given those probabilities
so let's say we have that path
and now let's calculate the value
of these boxes given that path so if i
walk into a four then my values are
three because remember
that the cost for for walking one box is
one
if i walk into that one my value is a
two therefore this one is
one for the next one is zero
and for the next one is minus one so
basically along my path
i keep subtracting one okay
and now what i'm gonna do is i'm going
to create a small
data set and that small data set
i'm going to be sending it to the neural
network so what i'm going to do is
for each point the gain is
the value at that point according to the
path
and i'm going to have the coordinates of
the point and the direction in which i
went
so i do this for every single one of the
points
sorry it's a little slow okay
and now now i'm gonna do the following
i'm gonna tell the neural network to
increase some of these directions and
decrease them
according to the game so i'm going to
tell the neural network you know what
when you're in the box with coordinates
0 2
that was pretty good because it gave me
a 3. so
please increase that the probability of
that direction
when i'm on the box with coordinates 0 1
that gave me at going up gave me a 2. so
that's pretty good so increase that
direction the property of that direction
when i was in the box with coordinates
one one and i moved left
i made one point so it's good increasing
when i'm at the point one zero i moved
up
that gave me zero points so don't don't
worry about those
and when i'm at the point zero zero and
i move right i actually lost the point
so decrease that probability so i'm
going to tell the neural network to do
all these things at the same time i'm
gonna feed all that information to the
neural network and i'm gonna tell you in
a bit how to do this
uh how to do this with math but
basically it's that
so let me do it one more example
i'm gonna walk in my step in in my in my
according to the policy that i have i'm
gonna number
each one of the
of the elements in the path with one
less because
each time that i walk i lose a point and
then at the last one i make five
so preview is four then the previous one
is three to one all the way to -3
and i'm going to create my data set uh
first i'm going to look at all the all
the directions that i went
these are the directions and these are
the directions that i'm going to tell
the neural network to update so i'm
going to create my data set
with the gain the coordinates and the
action
so for each point i have the gain
the coordinates of the point and the
action that i took now some of those
actions were good
some of them were not so good which one
was good
the one that gave me four points which
one was not so good
well the one that gave me minus three
points was
was pretty bad right so for that one
i tell the neural network to to think of
it less
whereas for the one that gave me four
points
i'm gonna tell the neural network to
improve that one
okay so i'm basically
so it's lagging a little bit
i'm telling you to increase the
probability of going right when you're
at the 0.45
i'm telling you to slightly increase the
remaining ones
and keep going down until you decrease
the final probability the one of moving
left
when you're at three one
sorry there's a little lag in my slides
so then i feed all this information
into the neural network okay so i tell
it you know what
some of these arrows are good make them
bigger some of these hours are more are
bad
make them smaller and i give all that
information to the neural network
and i continue doing that so if i do
that forever
i continue doing that many times always
fitting that information into the neural
network
and eventually i will have something
that
that is pretty well trained
okay so i take another path i take
another path
and so on
so eventually i end up with something
pretty good i end up with
a pretty decent policy that will tell me
how to walk in the best possible
direction
okay and i'll tell you very briefly
about how to train the neural network
basically
if you think of uh this is more for
people who know what uh who have trained
neural network before
uh if you have the weight train new
network is by features and labels right
so you
train it so that it gives you the right
label according to the features
and so what you do if you want it for
example to output a one when you say
four or five then if the neural
network's outputting anything else for
example a 0.2
that's what you got what you want is the
one so you tell the neural network
to increase that 0.2 and actually
because of derivatives
uh you want to degrade gradient ascent
and you actually tell it to increase the
logarithm of 0.2
so that's the gradients and step well if
you're going to train the policy network
then you do something very similar
right instead you you want it to
let's say that your input is 4 5 and
your output
is the direction that you took in the
path
and so let's say that the probability
that the neural network gave you
was 0.2 and what you wanted
was one so you tell the neural network
you know what
i want you to increase uh what you gave
me for that
for those features so increase the 0.2
and actually because of gradient ascent
i want to increase the logarithm of 0.2
except i remember that we had a gain
right so we had the gain that if it was
good
i want to increase that probability and
if it was bad i want to decrease it so
if my gain is for example four
i do a trick which is that i increase
four times the logarithm of 0.2
so i have that uh that is my new
gradients and step so it's it's it's
bigger if the value is higher so i
increase
more of the values if the gain is higher
and if the gain was for example negative
one
if it's um sorry negative three if it's
a bad step
then i use that in my gradient descent
step to actually decrease the
probability of going in that direction
so this part is a little technical
but it's just to tell you that that it's
a small trick that we use to
to train the policy network and then
finally when we have the trained policy
network
then all we have to do uh is
is his usage right so this is a small
summary
the way you train it is by taking random
paths
with those paths you build a small data
set as
a small data set with the gain and the
coordinates of the point and
the direction that you want to go or
that you went in
in that particular path
and some lagging a little bit
so you have the gain you have the
the coordinates you have the action
and then you'll never return some
probability well you want
to increase the ones on the top and to
decrease the ones on the bottom
because you want to increase the ones
with high gain decrease the ones with
low gain
so therefore you increase
you you increase the logarithm
multiplied by the gain and that way you
do a trick
sorry my lights are about 10 seconds
behind me
not too much running on the computer
and that's it that's pretty much what
policy gradients are
so once you have the policy gradient
then you simply have your agent
you have your neural network the neural
network tells you which direction to
move because it gives you the four
probabilities
and then you just follow those
probabilities you know you take the
input the input is the
the coordinates of the point then your
number spits out four probabilities
so you use those four probabilities to
tell you
with what probability to move in each
direction and then you move in the
direction
that that your policy tells you and in
that way
you gain at the game you win the game so
that's all that's all i have so thank
you very much for your attention
and if you have any questions feel free
to ask them on the chat
and again i'd like to remind you that uh
this is a book i wrote
with manning editors grocking machine
learning and the discount code is
twitter 40. so write it down
and it not it's not only for this book
but it actually saw a discount code for
the entire
catalog at manning so feel free to go
use it
uh other ways to follow me if you want
to follow my youtube channel i have lots
of videos like this one
and you can find me as luis serrano on
youtube
and this is my twitter handle lewis
likes math
and my page where all this information
is including the book and discount codes
is serrano dot academy so
thank you very much
you